Hey,
so last week you talked about how you
hated people ask you if you believe in God
and or do you believe miracles are,
you just liked those questions at least,
but you also talked about how,
and I want to put words in your mouth,
but I think he said
something about the ideas,
an empirical evidence for religious
experiences or spiritual experiences.
And I wonder how those two ideas like
can a spiritual existence or can a
spiritual experience exist
without God or how did I,
I had,
who knows,
who knows?
You know,
I don't know what.
I don't know what to make of that.
I mean,
you could,
it depends on what you're
willing to accept as proof.
I suppose that's where things get tricky,
you know,
if you have to demonstrate the existence
of God objectively than subjective
experiences of the
transcendent are irrelevant.
Right?
But,
and that's a perfectly
reasonable standpoint.
If your initial presupposition is the
only thing that has actual existence is
those things that can be
demonstrated objectively.
And I'm not putting that down.
Like that's a powerful methodology.
Our technology is basically
dependent on the acceptance,
at least a partial
acceptance of those axioms.
But I also think that it's difficult
for me to deny the existence of these
patterns of thinking that seemed
to exist cross culturally,
like the existence of the
representation of the Dragon,
for example.
Especially given that I
can see an evolutionary
rationale for the emergence of
these representations.
So,
and then there's also the indisputable
fact that religious experiences are
accessible to people through
a number of different avenues.
Now,
and one of the things I mentioned
when I discussed this before as well,
you could say,
well,
those are no different than
experiences of psychopathology,
but they are different
because the experiences of
psychopathology damage people,
where's the evidence is that
the transcendent experiences
actually help people.
So unless you can,
unless you're willing to say,
well,
there are some forms of psychopathological
experience that actually facilitate
health,
which is a possibility.
But you know,
I think you're,
you're pushing your hypo yearly
hypothesis at that point.